(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] So,
- You've been doing lot of
impressions on the show.
You're so great at impressions.
- [Seth] Thank you. I'm
so not, but thank you.
- You are!
- No, no, no.
- Stop it!
- I have been doing
- Do you need a fan to?
(audience laughs)
Stop it, with the fan.
The window is hot!
No, but is it something
you've always been good at?
Or did you like practice?
- I do want to point out
that this like window
is like a magnifying glass
and we're the ants,
- That's what I said!
- It coming through
- That's literally what
I said in rehearsals.
When you were a kid
and you had a magnifying
glass on the playground
and you'd get the ant, and
that's really messed up,
but you know, you'd just
be like, wow, that happens.
Yeah, or what?
- I watched other kids do it.
- Yeah, me too.
- You did it?
- No, I mean, I, you know,
I don't even remember if I did it,
but I know we all were out there.
- That's why the rats are staring at you.
They're like, we heard.
Our ants friend told us, we know.
- We know who you are
- Oh Kelly's "so nice"
(laughter)
- Ant Killer.
It's like, no, it is really hot,
but wait, do you, did you
grow up doing impressions?
- No, I didn't do impressions at all
and I was terrible at
doing impressions on SNL
and then I just, you know,
- [Kelly] No you weren't!
- No, I was
- You're a liar!
- But no, I don't we like to pretend,
we like to talk about how bad I am
at the impressions on the show
- [Kelly] Oh
- And that's
but you know, but that's probably,
that's that thing of
like "Aren't I terrible?"
and just like desperate for praise.
(laughter)
Yeah.
- Clap for me.
- [Seth] Yeah, yeah
- Who have you, have you
done impressions of people?
- [Seth] All right here's the thing,
it's very polarizing at the show.
A lot of people in the staff
think I do a terrible Vince Vaughn.
I'm going to do my Vince
Vaughn for you ready.
- Okay
(audience cheers)
I love Vince Vaughn!
- Don't build it up.
- [Kelly] (laughs) just to be
All right, ready?
- [Kelly] Yes.
It's a three-word impression
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And it's the same word three times.
Ready.
Buddy, buddy, buddy.
(audience cheers and laughs)
- [Kelly] So you know how much I love you.
- Yeah.
- That was not good.
(laughter)
- See?
- Buddy, buddy, buddy?
- No, that's like,
because Vince Vaughn is often
trying to convince someone
who was a friend of his,
- Yeah.
- To do a bad idea.
And he often like prefaces it,
be like, buddy, buddy, buddy.
(laughter)
- [Kelly] It was a
little better that time.
- It's already getting worse.
(laughter)
- So is it true that before you got SNL
that you were actually
trying to make a living doing
commercials? Is that true?
- No, I wasn't trying to like make it,
like I would go to auditions
- [Kelly] Yeah
- For commercials.
- [Kelly] Yeah, but
that's making a living.
It's paying the bills.
- [Seth] Eh, when you saw what
they paid you, not really.
(laughter)
I did a commercial
for a furniture store
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Where I,
this is my line.
I remember, I don't remember the name.
Let's say it was Chicago Couches.
- Okay.
- [Seth] It was something
along the lines of
"At Chicago Couches they
put the customer first.
That's me, I'm the customer."
(laughter)
Pretty good.
And I will tell you, I
did not get paid enough
to buy a couch.
- I did not, oh my God.
- [Seth] Yeah, it wasn't a lot.
- People always think that
once you're on TV you make
- [Seth] They think!
- [Kelly] They think that
That's the thing, they see on TV once
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They think you've got
money for everybody.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you're like, I don't
even have couch money.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I remember even after
idol, people thought,
oh gosh, she's like loaded.
No, you're not,
- [Seth] Oh yeah.
- They lie.
They say, oh it's a million dollars.
And it's like "contract" you never see it.
(laughter)
You never, it's like nope.
- [Seth] They show you a million dollars
- Yeah, yeah.
But you came close to getting a commercial
playing Mr. Summer Man?
- [Seth] Mr. Summer Man.
- I need to know Mr. Summer Man
- I came very close to Mr. Summer Man.
- [Kelly] Who is Mr. Summer Man?
And this was, it was for Sonic.
It was for
- [Kelly] Oh, like the place to eat?
- [Seth] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And I was really close.
And this would have changed everything.
- [Kelly] Would you, did you
have to wear rollerskates?
- [Seth] No.
- Oh
- I don't know what I had to do.
- Because they do that.
- Yeah.
But you know, it was
then, one of my closest,
you remember those two Sonic
guys in the drive through?
- Yes!
- One of them is my oldest friend.
- [Kelly] Really?
- Pete Grosz.
- [Kelly] I love those!
- The guy who's usually driving.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so that was the real burn.
- Okay cause your friend got it.
- [Seth] I was supposed
to be Mr. Summer Guy
Next thing I know he's the
Sonic guy for 20 years.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
Sonic is good.
- [Seth] I was really very,
it's actually deeply rude
that you brought up Mr. Summer Man
(laughter)
- I really wanted to
know what it entailed,
then if you had to wear roller skates.
I just pictured you roller
skating around a Sonic.
- [Seth] Yeah, I just remember that,
I didn't get it.
(laughter)
- Aww (laughs)